coût
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
denis qu'elle soit aujourd'hui un sujet
de penser qu'on pourrait sortir de la
ville pour profiter des couleurs en même
temps on peut ainsi retrouver des profs
district on semble d'achat par exemple
oui ça donne quoi
une fois l'intérim
merci ok on fait ça passe en avait
avant de partir maintenant je retiens
j'ai toujours mieux les faits la maison
j'achète mon deuxième chez mais très
frais j'ai contre aux atrocités d'europe
mais sans vraiment contrôler sur le gros
paquet de fric on y va à l'épicerie spar
solo ça
[Musique]
après des informations de cartes à la
compétence des douches et le boeuf haché
et la catégorie de viande la plus vendue
et la plus populaire
on l'a près de toutes sortes de façons
dans de nombreux plats comme vous
l'épicerie s'intéresse à son contenu en
grâce à son étiquetage et à sa
fabrication
mais que contient le boeuf haché roberti
elle connaît bien la réponse puisqu'ils
forment les bouchers de demain dans la
législation canadienne il n'y a que du
boeuf qui peut rentrer à l'état doive
cacher dans le boeuf haché on retrouve
de la viande de boeuf de vaches de
taureaux bref de bonnes idées
peu importe l'âge et le sexe de boeuf
haché c'est la finalité de la guerre en
fait plus rien après ce qu'on peut pas
transformée en steaks
en rôti en cuba obligatoire dans les
embauches et les coûts et les coûts qui
sont ici ce sont les morceaux qui sont
extrêmes du si on les muscles peut-être
les plus durs qu'ils s avec les jarrets
donc automatiquement ça va aller dans la
viande hachée
ici vous voyez vous avez les aponévrose
qui sont sur la viande qui peuvent faire
partie du boeuf haché c'est dur c'est
normal mais ça fait partie d'avions dash
n'ya pas problème est que la loi ne nous
oblige pas l'enlever pour notre enquête
nous avons choisi au hasard des
supermarchés de cinq grands d'asnières à
longueuil laval et montréal
nous avons pris dans chaque supermarché
un paquet de boeuf haché extra maigre
maigre et me maigre pour un total de
trente échantillons
première constatation trois bannières
sur six lots glace provigo super c
utilise des étiquettes non conformes à
la réglementation sur les paquets de
boeuf haché composée de partis fraîche
et décongelé nous avons montré ces
étiquettes à l' agence canadienne de
l'inspection des aliments
voici un exemple fr et des oeufs et fr
et fr oedème la réglementation est assez
clair on doit pas utiliser
d'abréviations on doit utiliser produit
décongelé
c'est presqu'île en réglementation c'est
ce qu'ont avant d'utiliser les termes
produit décongelé qu'il n'y pas fait ici
si cette mention ne figure pas
correctement sur l'étiquette
elle doit absolument apparaître sur un
écriteau placée près du produit certains
des marchands concernés reconnaissent
qu'il ya un problème et travaille à
apporter des correctifs
nos résultats ont aussi été communiquée
à louise rozon directrice d'option
consommateurs c'est effectivement une
lacune importante de retrouver des
abréviations sur les étiquettes pour ce
genre d'informations là puisqu'il s'agit
d'une information extrêmement important
pour le consommateur et qui touche à la
sécurité alimentaire
donc lorsqu'on voit des abréviations on
juge que c'est inacceptable et qu'on
devrait indiquer clairement au
consommateur s'il s'agit d'un produit
frais ou d'un produit décongelé parce
que s'il s'agit d'un produit qui a déjà
été décongelé
ça peut avoir comme conséquence que si
on le sait pas on peut tout simplement
acheté le produit et le faire congeler à
nouveau et donc ça peut à ce moment-là
causer un problème au niveau de la
sécurité alimentaire puisqu'on sait
qu'une viande on ne doit pas la faire
congeler deux fois autre constatation
certaines étiquettes porte la mention
est tout ce qui nous laisse dans le
doute
s'agit-il d'un produit frais ou de
produits décongelés parce que si la
réglementation est assez clair aussi on
peut mélanger des partis qui ont été
décongelé à des parties fraîchement
color la réglementation stipule qu'on
doit dire fait à partir de partis
fraîche et congelée voyez dans ce que
s'ils avaient ou le kit un petit peu
ambigu en ce qui regarde maintenant le
pourcentage de gras du boeuf haché la
loi canadienne des aliments et drogues
dit que pour avoir le droit d'être
vendues comme extra maigre le boeuf
haché doit contenir moins de 10 % de
gras le maigre -2 17% et le mit maigre
-2 23%
notre attaque est de boeuf haché ont
donc été soumis à une analyse très
précise du tout de gras dans un
laboratoire certifié
première constatation que ce soit dans
les catégories h'mimed maigre ou extra
maigre 28 des 30 échantillons étaient
moins gras que la loi oblige
bonne nouvelle pour nous la grande
surprise de notre enquête
sept des dix paquets de boeuf haché me
maigres sont en réalité du maigre
puisqu'ils contiennent moins de 17 % de
gras j'ai acheté ces deux boeuf haché
avant de venir vous rencontrer et maigre
et l'autre ennemi maigre mais allez
regarder tous les deux il me semble pas
mal la même chose sauf qu'on voit très
bien que le pourcentage de matière
grasse je dirais même rigueur que le
maigre est plus grand que le nid mer si
vous regardiez un petit peu là la
contenance de gracq et là je dirais que
lui et plaindre que lui peut-on conclure
que la fabrication du boeuf haché relève
davantage de l'approximation que de la
science exacte dans la dissuasion
actuelle c'est vraiment la compétence du
boucher qui va être capable de définir à
l'oeil nu
la contenance de matières grasses qui se
trouve dans une viande comme il y a peu
d'informations sur les étiquettes et
bien fait bien difficile pour le
consommateur de voir c'est quoi la
différence qu'il y a effectivement entre
la viande nimègue et la viande maigre
donc nous ce qu'on se disait à la
lecture de ces résultats là il serait
intéressant que l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des animes des aliments ou
oblige les marchands à étiqueter le tout
de grands réel qu'on retrouve dans les
viandes
[Musique]
c'est sûr et certain que le goût c'est
le grand lâche t il y en a qui est
extrêmement maigre n'a pas de goût donc
ce que vous avez fait pour lui donner du
goût alias assaisonner veulent ajouter
des jaunes d'oeufs qui va devenir du
cholestérol aussi très spécial mais le
plus intéressant dans le sable face à
nimègue de bonne qualité c'est vraiment
idéal la cuisson nous démontre aussi
qu'une fois le gras fondu il y à bien
peu de différences entre le maigre et le
mit maigre ici donc on a celui qui était
mineure le gras va automatiquement
sortait pendant la cuisson
voyez quand même car pratiquement aucune
matière grasse devant pareil et on peut
terminer avec celui qui peuvent fâcher
même encore une fois nous allons le voir
qu'il est extrêmement bien accueilli
alors lequel vous voyez à même aucune
matière grasse est vraiment ce qu'on
retrouve sur les sucreries sont
caramélisées au fond de la poêle
[Musique]
lors de votre prochaine visite au
comptoir de boucherie si à l'oeil vous
n'arrivez pas différencier le maigre et
le mit maigre il n'est peut-être pas
nécessaire de dégraisser votre
portefeuille
je suis assez fort utiles les résultats
de votre étude puisque le conseil qu'on
va donner aux consommateurs à partir de
maintenant mais ils ne paient pas de
dollars de plus le kilo pour la viande
hachée maigres puisque vous retrouver la
plupart du temps dans le produit ni
maigre un produit équivalent
[Musique]
les odeurs de fromages forts envahissent
votre frigo
qu'à cela ne tienne il s'agit d'avoir
sous la main une branche de thym frais
que vous déposerez dans le compartiment
à fromage le thème masquera alors la
présence des odeurs désagréables un truc
simple mais efficace
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y en eu des marques
il me semble que je passe mon temps à la
remplacer ma pole dance adhésif mais
tout le savoir s'en servir toujours pas
l'abîmer
oui je veux bien mais il faut surtout
savoir bien la choisir
[Musique]
premier test qu'on a effectués c'était
la cuisson de neuf singles
sur les cinq fois lors deux deux poils
ont réussi la cuisson d'un sain qu'il y
a des yeux 5 leur cote
les trois autres elle les germes donc ça
veut dire que si on utilise une très
faible quantité de drogue et 5 pour
répondre à ce critère elle a ainsi aidé
cette fois ci ce qui très bon ces dates
et fall
c'est très malsain c'est beaucoup plus
minces n'a pas de fonds a renforcé l de
fond est très épais les plus lourdes et
dahmane et deux épées dans
l'enracinement de l'existant
la gatineau n'a pas non plus de défendre
en farsi la circulaire elle n'est pas de
deux fois on a forcé mais le métal est
très épais l'impasse à des fonds l'a
toujours à considérer dans la chaude
pour l'ong
vous
différents poignet les meilleurs était
la star fait à cause de la plaque ce qui
est caoutchouteuse et il ya un endroit
pour le poste pour bien manoeuvre
électrique plus que confortable
à ce que l'on veut faire c'est évaluer
la résistance des 1 18 ati adhésif nord
pour ce faire on va est gratifié vous
frottez perna trois minutes
le fonds des poids lourds avec une
spatule à métal ce que je vous
déconseille télé fortement d'après chez
vous c'est parti
ça gronde déjà des marques de piercing
[Musique]
si on regarde dans l'ensemble là c'est
le culot c'était celle qui a le mieux
résisté à l'usure accélérée évidemment
c'est un bêta de halo un bon match c'est
un prix moyen de 1 40 dollar
c'est un très bon achat je serai très
teintée de refaire un autre show comme
celui là c'est celle que le moins bien
réussi aussi à cause la fragilité de
l'appareil
moi je connais mais des conseillers
jeunes lettre personnelle mais je le
referais stadium à 60 dollars évidemment
de et être un peu cher le site merizzi
terre malgré on y voit des traces
d'usures très résister culinairement
parlant c'est celle qui donne au
parlement les meilleurs résultats
les athées par dreyer résistance pour 21
13 50 euros c'est évident et marquant un
peu fragile donc pour cuisiner c'est
beaucoup fred gel c'est plus difficile
d'obtenir de bons résultats
moi personnellement c'est pas vraiment
un poêlon qui m'attire beaucoup de la
donner à la star ferait elle était
surprenant
les huttes fini de mai ces cellules est
là mais c'est quand même pas dramatique
un excellent avant d'aller dans sa gamme
de prix à 26,26 dollars c'est sur ma
meilleure amie
[Musique]
non on a tout ce qu'il faut oui on peut
aller un peu serré celle là
des coûts
à moins que la garde la bande de gaza
s'est calmé bon ben on part en centre
ville
[Musique]
les choux choux fleurs les tuer et
pinard contiennent souvent de la terre
et parfois des insectes
surtout lorsqu'ils sont fraîchement
cueillies du potager qu'à cela ne tienne
pour se débarrasser des bestioles
indésirables
il suffit de s'en remettre au bon vieux
vinaigre blanc de une à deux cuillères à
soupe de vinaigre blanc dans l'eau de
lavage des légumes et les insectes
flotteront à la surface de l'eau et ne
vous reste plus qu'à tirer le bouchon de
l'évier pour vous en débarrasser
un truc simple mais efficace il nous
ferait plaisir d'avoir de nouvelles
alors vous pouvez composer sans frais le
1 800 0 88 81
et si vous êtes de la région de montréal
le 54 7 9 0 88 81
consultez aussi notre site internet au
triple w pour un taux canada.ca barres
obliques l'épicerie
[Musique]
oh
bonne décoller au dernier pic nic dawes
poche ou mais c'est beaucoup c'est une
question je me posais faut que j'aie une
carotte comme celle ci na li a
certainement la même question tout le
monde se pose
cette coach comme ça d'un net s'est
amené on arrive sur vos terres vous êtes
le seul producteur de l'uni carottes au
québec je pense que vous êtes la
personne pour répondre à notre première
question le mystère là une carotte est
ce que c'est une variété de petites
carottes
est ce que selon carottes qu'on a coupé
en petits morceaux ou est ce que ces
bébés carottes qu'on a pas laissé mûrir
malheureusement c'est pour petite
carotte un bébé cas là c'est pas une
petite kern augustine kara qui vient
environ 30 cm de long avec environ tour
ou encore de poser de diamètre au collet
au feuillage qui est coupée en section
de 5 centimes et là on est sous vos
chats mêlée ce qui est incroyable c'est
qu'on se retrouve neuf un champ de saint
nazaire où sont vos car la suède mais
les carottes sont assez de ce filet puis
trois rivières sncf et pourquoi pas
ailleurs pourquoi pas chez le voisin
immédiat le mans n'ont pas vraiment
apprécié au sérieux à l'époque parce que
il n'y avait pas de marché
c'était le marché la carotte celle au
conventionnel qui prenait la grosse part
du marché
de fait les gens propres sont vraiment
sérieux puis on a rencontré un monsieur
maintenant que lui on est intéressé
juste à main était venu nous voir c'est
qu'à rodez était beaucoup trop grosse
mais il y avait un intérêt de produit le
produit puis par la suite beaucoup
d'ajustements fin donc on a commencé à
travailler avec ce monsieur
ça a pris quelques uns mais aujourd'hui
une fourni un produit
[Musique]
laissé à mener ont vite quitté le champ
on regarde l usine
il paraît qu'elle traverse bien des
étapes avant de se retrouver dans nos
épiceries la carotte pour commencer
lorsque les récolter et la rue des
taupes calibré par diamal toute la
calotte qui tous encore de pousser - se
retrouvent ici ce qui est trop grosse
lan ou presque pour cent vont dans
d'autres usines de transformation
ensuite des travées super camion oui
c'est un camion réfrigéré et porte les
réfugiés est très important pourquoi la
carotte pendant environ deux chiens dans
les duos période de chaleur l'été
environ 80 grilles fermées
il faut le redire à 32 degrés fahrenheit
le plus rapidement possible parce que
chaque camp redditionnelle comprend pour
l'heure choisie comme près d'un mot de
conservation de moins
on prend les bacs de mouron les buts
dans l'eau au cou et comment la suivre
sont inspectés manuellement
j'ai des machines qui courent une
section de 5 centimes à tous les bouts
sont toutes petites 506 my horse urgent
de convoyant qui enlève je te met aussi
blocs sont pauvres sont peu de rire sont
ouvertement mais visuellement sont pas
donc se racheter
vous vous retrouvez des coeurs avec la
paire pour celle là c'est parler jusqu'à
soixante dix pour sa perte
les gones qui arrêtent continue dans la
pelouse abrasives un bricolage qui font
un peu large sera la suite à sa voix
dans une autre machine climatique
son appel soit l'étape du polissage
urgent de papier semble aimer puidoux
ensuite son calibre et encore par diamal
je viens sur ce marché
[Musique]
est ce que c'est une carotte existait un
celle où auparavant ce que c'est la même
une carotte que de l'utiliser c'est une
variété de carotte c'est l'eau qui était
abandonné au cours des années puis été
repris justement pour le coton pire le
bébé car on s aime justement à haute
densité
puis elle est sensible comme son père
devillé nombre de variétés ses shows
carcenac sun ken rock qui a presque pas
de car ce type de kendo a comparé aux
autres types de kerra c'est rechercher
sur wii c'est exactement ce que ça prend
pour faire le clown pipo
pourquoi parfois quand on garde notre
sac au frigo il comme les carottes
devienne comme nuland
comme s'il y avait je sais pas quelque
chose que comme un 16 détériorée qui
plombe ça c'est un type de bactérie
novak til actif est une bactérie qui
transforme le suc dakar hot avis n'est
simplement pièce déconvenue
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi nous ça mais c'est
surtout pour des collations ou
collectives parce que ça va d'un grand
compétition avec les friandises donc
remplacer une collation gratuite faire
une collection sans fil mais ce que des
gens qui cuisinent avec ça j'imagine que
mon album de mc oui oui mais à la maison
on emmène aspect gatif parce qu'il soit
possible il est prêté on a seulement
quelques oublis
[Musique]
à l'halloween les citrouilles font leur
apparition par milliers sur le marché
nous les achetons principalement comme
décoration dans la majorité des cas
elles se retrouveront à la poubelle dès
le lendemain de la fête de nos jours peu
de gens les utilisent en cuisine
[Musique]
pourtant les citrouilles et les autres
courges membres de la famille des
curcubitacé sont consommés par l'homme
depuis plus de dix mille ans ils sont
les fruits d'une plante potagère annuel
apparenté au melon et au concombre et
elle existe dans une multitude de
variétés les amérindiens guérissait les
européens atteints de ce corps but en
leur faisant manger de la purée de
giraumon ou turban tanada excellente
source de vitamines a et c et de
potassium les ancêtres des courges
seraient originaires d'amérique centrale
elle était cultivée avec le maïs et les
fèves par les aztèques les incas et les
mayas christophe colomb fut le premier
occidental à connaître ses fruits
ici dans l'industrie alimentaire la
citrouille est utilisé entre autres pour
fabriquer la fameuse sosa et grands la
sauce aux prunes qui devrait plutôt
s'appeler sauce à la citrouille
gaubert bah oui mais nous les certaines
on sait quoi faire rêver nos lycées
droid ou grand mère connaissait bien les
vertus des citrouilles l on faisait des
compotes d'état et des potages
l'orage getty meilleure qu'elle est
écrite alors pourquoi ne pas revenir aux
traditions de notre continent et
redonner aux courges citrouilles et
potirons une plus grande place dans
notre alimentation
[Musique]
soit faire avec mais j'ai décidé de
faire ce que je fais mais conserve la
compa de la gelée d'état
d'ailleurs je trouve c'est vrai que ça
fait beaucoup
étudier chez nous mais des allées pas
les non moins que les je voyais aller
peut-être au fait
en terminant voici les bons achats de la
semaine le brocoli est fraîchement
récoltés et les dc il est beau et bon
malgré le printemps fois la récolte de
chou est abondant donc les prix sont bas
les canneberges fraîches sont également
en magasin congelés l'est parce qu'elle
approche des fêtes et prix augmenteront
les variétés de pommes tardy sont en
magasin même si elles sont un peu plus
petits
elles sont fermées savoureuse parmi
celles ci la coke donné la mcintosh sont
à prix spécial dans certains
supermarchés
sachez que les clémentines du maroc et
d'espagne sont arrivées elles sont moins
sucré en début de saison
elles seront donc à leur meilleur un
dessin ombre si vous n'avez pas encore
acheté votre site web pour l'halloween
il ya un peu moins de choix et bien sûr
les prix sont légèrement plus élevés
bonnes épiceries